landmine pressed for shoulders and it's
so safe just feels right doesn't it just
feel like the right thing to do but
that's because you've managed to take a
movement that was supposed to be
pressing vertically and made it go a
little bit more close to a bench press
if you lie under it like that
i would say don't use a pre-workout
these things are false economies i don't
agree with that apart from the times
when you injure yourself which isn't
usually due to the workout it's due to
something else that's going on you
almost never regret going to the gym
another life hacks episodes tools
techniques and tactics for a productive
and efficient life we're going to go
through a big list of things that we've
used over the last couple of months
and everything will be linked in the
show notes below because it's january we
thought that we would do some special
gym
training little exercises that we've
picked up
variations on workouts maybe some
kitchen hacks but also probably some
things from the internet and maybe some
netflix shows and such like that we've
been enjoying
so johnny
what have you what have you got for us
so my this is my exercise variant
cool
um so
this is i guess if you are in a gym that
doesn't necessarily have a chest press
or something like that um or if you
suffer from
back pain consistently or an aggravated
lower back
and find that for example when you're
doing bench you're doing dumbbell
variants that like it irritates your
back when they sort of cramp up it's a
pretty simple variation but it's one
that probably people outside of the like
strength trading world might not have
tried which is just a it's a bench press
normal bench press with your feet up not
necessarily on the bench but not like
straight out um so your feet aren't on
the floor basically you aren't applying
any force onto the floor and it
basically turns it into
chest isolation and completely removes
your lower back completely removes your
body um so just a good variation limits
the limits the load and
very quick to warm up for
so
how does it replace a peck
machine is it it's just a bench press
right it is but it's so like
i guess it depends on how you would
normally bench but a lot of people even
if they're not a power lifter you'll see
them kind of as the bench gets harder
they'll sort of like squirm and move
around and like press their feet on the
ground to try and like
use their the rest of their body to help
the weight up when your feet down on the
ground you can't you can't do that
i'm guessing as well the angle is you're
a little bit more flat as opposed to
decline because you can't get that arch
in right okay exactly yeah so you
basically have to lie flat which means
that you can't get the like the lower
back cramping that sometimes happens um
it's also quite a good um like if you if
you don't really feel like scared of
bench press and you want to just use
light weight but you want to still get
something out of it it's a good way of
doing that as well what's the reason
biomechanically that this is harder is
because you can't use your lap your lats
as much you can't recruit like
technically
legs and lower body there's no like
there's less stability because you're
not like you're relying on balance at
the same time oh okay there's no force
through the floor and yeah you aren't in
a in as much of an arch if you wanted to
compare it to a powerlifting bench press
have either of you ever tried it
yeah it's nice
so i the only time i would have done
that would have been if i was doing
bench press from the floor that flopped
like a floor press yeah yeah uh that's
the only time that i would have done
that do you get do you have you i
imagine you have yousef well like you're
benching and your back like
cramps up seizes up
yeah it doesn't take much for my back to
yeah i can imagine
i really thought you would have had that
chris
you've not experienced that before no so
my
my back doesn't really seem to be too
extension uh
perturbed but it gets flexible yeah yeah
a little bit worse when i go
when i go forward yeah that's nice i
like it um
i need to try that i might try that
i'll try and add that in this week
seth what have you got what's yours
so mine is probably one that we're all a
fan of unfortunately
this is a sexist exercise variation can
i guess what it is yes
is it
barbell chest supported row my favorite
exercise in the world
so if you do have back problems or if
you
just find that you're in this cycle of
doing bent over barbell rows or pendlay
rows and then each time you add the
weight you're just like humping it a
little bit more and then over the months
you're like well did i increase my row
by 2.5 kilos or did i just hump 2.5
kilos more and it's it gets to the point
where like if you're rowing more than
your body weight
mechanically like balance wise you can't
actually
keep it strict because
it'll just topple you over
so there is a point where beyond 80 or
100 kilos you're gonna have to start
doing some kind of chest supported
variation to get a strict back workout
so just give it a go set up a bench on i
i say from flat it's up two inclines
so two clips um
get the seat of the bench up as well so
that you can rest your knees on it
or if uh if it's one of those benches
that has feet then
dig your toes into the feet make
yourself as stable as possible
and then barbell with you know normal
plates on on the side so it gives you
enough range
and then each rep counts as when you
touch the
underside of the bench with
and then it keeps it replicable what's
your reason for doing incline
bench chest supported row as opposed to
setting a bench up across two boxes and
it being perfectly flat
you can do that as well it's just pretty
janky just convenience
yeah most
most gyms i've been to
don't really have a safe setup for doing
it because you
continue
to train
out of very specific types of gyms and
they're the ones close to me
geographically
most gyms i've been to that are within a
five-minute bike ride yeah i don't have
this that's it but i because the only
thing that i think with that i love it i
i think it's a great movement both me
and you of everyone who has had back
pain at some point and
i've never been a fan of bent over rose
i think that they're too easy to cheat
and it just feels like what am i working
here am i working my hamstrings my
glutes my lower back my shoulders my
traps my upper back like so sometimes
you'll do a set of pendlay rows and
you'll be like i actually feel that most
in my lower back yeah what have i done
there yeah um i had one just attached to
that which is what you just said chris
which is a seal row which is what you
just described so again when you're
lying flat and you row you basically
reverse bench press yeah yeah and you're
pulling it to like the bottom of the
bench you can get specific benches that
are
just achieving high thin
uh seal road benches yeah they're called
didn't the place in edinburgh have one
of those you
most likely in fact that's the direct
upside down version of the first
exercise you described johnny yeah yes
yes
like a seal completely flat the reason
it's called a seal row i think is
as you start getting closer and closer
to failure i don't know why this is but
your feet do the thing you just like
you know you know like those uh red
red fish that you lay on your hand and
they do you know what i mean it's like a
like a thin piece of see-through paper
usually a present in a christmas cracker
from 1997. yeah you must know what that
is chris no it's like it's like a
see-through piece of plastic if it's a
fish okay if you know what we're talking
about put your thing in the comments
below
i had a few here because i thought that
we were going i thought that we would
have a couple each so the first one
which is my favorite and i think i've
during training with you guys we've both
done this uh
skull crushers but floor-lying skull
crushers
so most of the time if you're doing a
skull crusher which is a tricep movement
you would do it on a bench um getting
yourself to the point where you have the
easy curl or the barbell up here
is actually a little bit awkward because
okay do i get it passed to my hips then
i've got to kind of hip it to my chest
then i've got to push it up and then get
it down dumping the bar is also really
difficult it's easier for you to go past
the range that you're supposed to you
can't do dead stops from it
all of this is fixed by doing
skull crushes from the floor because you
lie down in front of the easy kill bar
it's already on the floor behind you you
can just put your hands behind you take
it up if you fail a rep
that you're not going to drop it on your
head you're going to just push it up a
little bit away from you drops on the
floor uh plus you can do some cool stuff
like it's easier for the person that's
with you to do
strip sets or drop sets because they can
just pull the weights off more easily
and you can do dead stop
sets as well because you can just lower
it to the floor wait until it's taken
all the momentum off and then go again
it's like
that for the long head of the tricep is
number numero uno workout exercise elbow
pain as well i think elbow pain with
normal normal skull crushes can be quite
bad for people if they they're
consistently like passing their head too
much extension yeah or just too much
going through the elbow so yeah the
commonality here is lots of lying down
[Laughter]
lots of removing the lower body apart
from a very specific part of the upper
body and
but the good thing is lots of
repeatability
uh so
oh sorry johnny it's yours
i just have i've got a couple more
exercise variations on me too i don't
know me too johnny
i've got some more fitness stuff here
all right hit
us maya reps
you both know what those are vintages no
so it's something that like again like
yousef and i'll just use all the time
but i think a lot of people won't have
tried so if you're short on time
um
you want to like add some assistance at
the end of your training session but
you're like you're not like i like i
don't really like doing kills for
example or like um direct arm work or
anything like that
my reps is basically um
i think it's
by a guy called borge for girly
um i think that's his name or something
like that so you do an initial set which
is called an activation set there's
usually like 10 to 15 reps near failure
and then you take ten breaths
and then do between three to five reps i
have done this i thought you might have
done ten breaths three to five reps and
you keep doing that until you hit like a
close to failure set basically you strip
the weight
you there are like variations where you
can do that but normally if you do it
properly and this is what's so good
about it you you get like
five minutes in
and you've done so many reps and you
knock it
and you're like okay that's all of that
movement done and it it removes all of
the resistance of like oh i've got five
sets of eight or i've got three sets of
twelve because it's just done before you
really know what's happened and you can
make it into a bit of a game so like
week by week you try and do
slightly more weight or you try and do
an extra set at the end or something
like that or do it in in less time like
take you a breath between
they're great the the rationale from is
it pronounced borge or burger
i think it might be pronounced like
or something it can't be bigger i
can't i i don't know but
you are g e
b o with the line through it which is
pronounced
so
it could be
anyway
the idea is the rationale
that you recruit the majority of your
motor units at
reps
seven eight and nine of a ten rep set if
that's close to your your max
and so you take your 12 rep max you do
10 reps with it you start to approach
that sort of almost failure point
you then stop three to five deep breaths
recycle the atp but you keep the kind of
fiber recruitment at that point and then
you just do two or three and then you
kind of ride the wave and stay at that
peripheral state and
supposedly those 30 reps that you do
end up being more effective than if you
had done three sets of 10 for example
yeah because in that second example
it would only be sets uh reps seven
eight and nine of all three sets that
were effective or sometimes even only
like the final set depending on the load
you use as well
yeah the only thing i wouldn't use this
for is
so it's great for
any isolation stuff most upper body
stuff i wouldn't use it for squat
deadlift leg press or anything like that
because that gets uh
quite a hairy question
why not for deadlift
just the like the total
body overwhelmed
like if you take like a if you take your
12 rep max on dead lift and do 10 reps
with it and then you're going to rep out
with that i think the chance of you
like if you're gonna do five five by
three
after that yeah okay i understand but i
think with ten rest in between as well
it just needs to be anything that's easy
to reset if it's a complex if it's a
standing shoulder press
like no because you're gonna have to
rack it and then take it off but if it's
something that's easy if you're doing
machine if you're doing any arm direct
arm work
perfect for machines like that don't do
it with like cleans or anything like
be reasonable also well that's crossfit
that's what crossfit is isn't it
um
also probably
better for
bilateral movements rather than
unilateral movements just that you're
going to be [ __ ] about with rest
periods in between
so i i do it for dumbbell row it's in my
program for dumbbell row i disagree with
it's the fact that it's in my program
for dumbbell row but it is so i do it
and i have to basically do the full
cycle on each side so you'll do like a
set of 15 3 3 3 3. so it takes twice as
long
but yeah you're doing it all right arm
well because if you try and do it the
other way around
you end up like forgetting where you are
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
do i need to start with the left or the
right yeah i understand and technically
you've what you've rested twice as long
per side yes so it's kind of defeating
like at that point you're just doing
dumbbell row yeah just high intensity
dumbbell row okay yeah so mayo reps i'd
totally forgotten about that dude i'm
gonna i'm definitely gonna add that back
in yeah it's like a it's somewhere
between a drop set it's a permanent drop
set um without the drop of the weight
isn't it or a rest pause it's like yeah
aggressive
training so something called dog crap
training which was sort of a similar um
similar style but it's it's more of a
family-friendly version i guess all
right seth what you got
so there is a place in most programs as
you as we were saying before to increase
the stability of the movement so that
you can focus on the muscle that you're
working
so up until recently i always did my
split squats so my bulgarian split
squats which is where
you hold two dumbbells you've got one
foot in front one rear foot resting on a
bench behind you at about kind of knee
height
and you're doing
squats like that that they're
notoriously brutal and there's loads of
memes going around like you know when
when your coach puts split squats in
your program and it's like tearing up
the paper because people just hate them
um but often when you're doing them a
lot of your bandwidth is focused on like
don't fall over like because you're
trying to balance laterally or
sagittally
rather than um focusing on the muscle
that you're training
so this was a tweak from
someone called dick who works with us
she is australian called rebecca um and
she's the originator of the biros you
know the little black
buyers as well she invented them um
but it's just to stabilize one hand
and so let's say you have your right
foot forward in a split squat
left foot behind you
you'd want to hold the dumbbell in the
opposite hand so your left hand
and then just hold on to a rack or
something
onto your
this is getting very surreal
hold on to something stable on your
right side
that way
you can just really focus on getting a
nice nice glutey sensation do you not
now
you're going to have to hold double the
weight in one hand if you're even
remotely like competent your grip is
going to be a problem here right could
be a problem so so actually i don't
think you should go too heavy with these
because what you've done there is you've
improved the quality of the movement you
can you can get more out of less
it's not a movement that i think you
need to like load super heavy
and you know even holding a 30 kilogram
dumbbell is going to be enough for most
people to get
some good stuff from and you can go up
to like 15 20 reps as well
single um
rearfoot
elevated
split squats with unilaterally loaded
yeah um okay so
this is from
a guy
on
uh instagram that i follow who has
some really cool
infographics that explain breakdowns dr
eddie joe phd uh on instagram and he
just breaks down what the sign says
about strength training and he looked at
the exercises which recruit the most
muscles at most muscle fibers for glute
development so what are the exercises
and out of 100 which was the maximum of
recruitment
the top three movements
are all types of step-ups so
the number one which i think is in the
90s was
step-ups
number two was like
contralateral cross-body step-ups and
number three was some other type of
step-up so basically overall and the
next closest thing was maybe rdls or
deadlifts way way way down were um
hip thrusts [ __ ] kickbacks
uh rear foot elevated split squats even
lunges were quite in fact lunges might
have been the next closest thing after
uh after the step ups but basically if
you want to have big glutes and if you
want to develop your glutes and if you
want to improve your lower back
just do step ups and the best way that
i've found to do this is dumbbells held
back again no not that not that thing
that athletes do where they go
all the time
um if you have your dumbbells by your
sides it means that you your center of
gravity is lower so you're actually more
stable it's easier for you to balance
you are only on one foot here as you go
up and go down um i wouldn't go above
about depending on how tall you are but
i wouldn't get your
thigh of the stepping up leg to ever be
really above
parallel to the ground you don't need to
get a super super amount of range here
you can just go from there and then push
to it being straight i would also do all
of one side at once
and then i wouldn't do it alternating
because just resetting each time foot
goes down foot comes up it's too complex
just keep one foot on and i think that
this is a hack i learned from you guys
which is when you step down to the floor
during step ups
only put your heel on the ground because
it means that you can't push off with
your toes you'll find yourself as you
start to fail the reps wanting to give
yourself a lift off at the bottom and i
guess if you're going super super heavy
it
it might give you a little bit of
assistance and help you to add some more
load it's probably a pretty good
movement to overload on because if you
need to fail it's quite easy it's
probably pretty safe on your lower back
because you're in this perfect straight
position and also you've just got
dumbbells on your hands so it doesn't
really matter um but yeah if you want to
make it if you want to go for the super
duper hard version uh only touch the
heel on the ground so you can't kick off
with your foot and
four by 12 on each leg
oh just totally disgusting it's a cardio
workout disguised as a strength workout
just make sure you go
if you curl up your
big toe
on the first rep so the foot that's on
the ground yeah the
left foot on the box
right foot on the ground curl up your
toes of your right foot and then load
the leg that's on the box first yep and
then step off so much harder just keep
that yeah posture yeah it is because
obviously this is the problem with
movements like this isn't it like if
you're aiming for a number of reps
you end up just doing anything to hit
that number of reps which is why we need
quality of movement rather than worrying
about trying to load them heavily well
that it feeds into my my my next oh
um which is to have
a split in your sessions where you have
um
well
if you care about how much weight you
lift at all have one or two movements in
the session where you do just care about
how much weight you lift because for
example if you're trying to increase
your bench press or your squat or your
deadlift or something like that i don't
think you should necessarily be focusing
on the quality of the contraction in
your glutes and your hamstrings you do
just want to be lifting more weight or
hitting your rept target but all of your
assistance stuff
i think in general you get far more
mileage out of yourself your joints your
muscles your collective tissue and the
exercise
if you say well okay this rowing
movement like i don't care how much how
many plates are on the machine
i'm gonna go for
like the best quality movement i'm going
to control the reps i'm going to go for
maximal contraction i'm going to pause
at the top and i'm going to use half the
weight that i maybe would have done and
it's a massive ego hit especially if you
train with people if you're using like
two-thirds of the weight that they are
but if by the time you hit the weight
that they are using now
almost guarantee
you'll be in a much better condition
than them so just reduces your injury
rate of injury um and also how much
longer you can use the exercise for as
well do you commit to certain movements
within your workout plan then being for
quality rather than for load
yeah so for me it's anything that i have
like four
four or five exercises that i care about
the um the number so those are
ironically considering what we're just
talking about seal row and chin up so
like a rowing movement and a vertical
pull squat bench and deadlift are the
only things that i like track how strong
i am everything else in my program even
really a lot of the assistance stuff so
like a pause squat or a pause deadlift
or a feet up bench press or anything
like that i'd rather take the hit on the
load and go for like what am i trying to
do here
like i want to feel something mind
muscle connection exactly yeah
this solves the problem people always
are like oh but i thought you have to
kind of pick powerlifting or
bodybuilding and there's no in between
and you have to
everything or you're either only lifting
wall weight and looking
fat and rubbish or or just being a
bodybuilder who's weak you know i know
it's a bit of an outdated kind of
mentality now
but it's okay to
lift more and also look like you lift
and
i would say
it's weird because we go through phases
with this right i think maybe because
i'm coming out the back of crossfit
and people
although it might not look like it on
the outside people are quite concerned
about doing exercises in there when
you're doing accessories really for
quality so i think on average when i
look in the gym
i see people that don't progressively
overload enough i see people that are
under
loaded
and overlifting a lot of the time how
many people are still bench pressing the
same weight that they were 10 years ago
are still going into the gym because
they've never actually committed to
doing
progressive overload so i think that the
way that you've got it split there which
is okay where am i looking to gain
strength commit to those that's for
strength and then on the other things
i'm committing to quality i think that's
a good way to do it because it allows
you to still become stronger because if
you did this is what
we have a a friend who did a
bodybuilding competition a long long
time ago and was adamant that going into
the gym and doing like
five
five reps 10 times
on a single arm row but with a 10 second
eccentric was going to be the best way
and he stepped on stage and didn't look
like he lifted because he'd been
convinced by a particular type of
train of some blog on the internet that
this was the optimal way to do it you're
like look mate if you just [ __ ] put
some weight on the bar you'd have
probably been fine
but you didn't i think the like the test
is what would happen with this exercise
if i had to really open the taps with it
like if there was a load that i'd never
lifted before and i had to really go for
it what would i end up doing so if you
imagine that with a barbell kill for
example and you had to really go for a
1rm like it feels unsafe doesn't it it
feels like you'd end up doing like lost
one of those one of those little plastic
fish that you get in a
christmas cracker you put your fingers
across the back of the yoyo
so if you're in a gym that doesn't have
a pull-down machine
that only has cables for example for
example
only within a couple of minutes of your
house and
then
you can get really not and in fact i
might start doing this instead of
pull-downs in the future
which is just a deep lunge with the
cable overhead and just doing single arm
pull dance so the way that i would do it
for the people who are lucky enough to
see this on youtube
is yeah are you wearing orange jogging
butter you like them no so
so a deep lunge yep arm overhead so
right foot forward left foot left hand
back knee on the ground there
uh you can but i just i'm flexible
enough to just
do it in a deep lunge with my foot on
the floor
so your back feels elevated backwards
off the ground sorry back knee
my back knee is yeah just because it
feels nice and stable that's a good
exercise so i have a buddy uh alfie
who's adamant a
kind of a similar movement but sat on
the floor uh with both cables attached
at the top two handles and then allowing
yourself to basically do a vertical kind
of like a pull down like a closed grip
pull down but because it's on the cables
and because you're not locked into a
seat it allows you to play around with
that angle and that stretch that you get
at the very very
yeah lovely as well yeah you can also do
that
with if there's like a
seat bit
you can put your foot on there
uh i know what you mean so that then you
can hinge yeah while keeping it reliable
uh this is
something that i think it was such a
good um
cue that i was given by a crossfit coach
and his argument was your concentric
should be quicker than the eccentric on
everything that you do
that if you're doing bicep curls and
you're lowering the weight down you can
lower it as slowly or as quickly as your
program demands for nine seconds yeah
for nine seconds like that other one but
um you need to contract it quicker than
that and i think that just generally
when i've seen people training effect
they're forgetting about tempo not
everything needs to be a tempo movement
not everything needs to be like a four
second eccentric but if you were to take
a little bit more care about how you're
lowering the weight down
and then you use power on the way up
i've also seen this maybe bro signs but
that
if power is loads whatever load distance
and speed pulled together that moving a
heavy weight more quickly recruits more
power so that should mean that you get
more muscular is that how accurate am i
here
absolutely physics lad there um
it's right though
that is correct
because that's why you track your bar
speed right johnny
um
no it's not
but
so i track my bar speed because
bar speed is has a correlation to rpe so
how many more reps i could have done so
it's a way of me managing the intensity
without using percentages okay uh what
do you think about
people integrating tempo better into
training
i think it can be it can definitely be
overused so i think the rule that i
would have is if you
like you're far better off with an
exercise in general just progressively
overloading it over time
than you are worrying about as long as
your tempo isn't
ridiculous like if you're throwing it
around i think you should have control
over the weight but you're probably
going to get more
mechanical tension muscle growth over
time if you just add more weight and
don't try and do like three seconds down
three second pause three seconds up um
because the tension created from using
10 more kilos is greater than the
tension with the the longer eccentrics
and concentrics we'll scrap tempo
everything and i'm just going to put
more weight on the bar
uh i'll lift it faster and lift it
faster okay joining i'm pulling the
ejector seat and uh i'm passing it on to
you because tempo everything was a bad
idea according to the two pts in the
room
uh well i've just literally just lost my
thing
your hack yeah
that's so annoying should i go
right
close
um
it is
to use a
um you both come across a landmine
attachment before
so
most gyms have them maybe not the ones
within five minutes of useless house but
mine actually does they do fantastic so
i find overhead pressing
in general quite cumbersome so barbell
over the head press i know chris is
ridiculously strong above all over her
press because just the forearm forearms
to rest the rest of the bar
but like that's that's cumbersome
getting dumbbells at a heavy enough
overhead is cumbersome um and also like
it's quite for example at a bar below
the head pressure and like leaning back
and all that sort of stuff so if you
load a land mine up which for people who
don't know that is basically a way of
anchoring a barbell to a fixed point and
then it's
leaning away and you hold it in your
hand
you're doing a one one-handed overhead
press with a landmine is a far more
natural movement because you naturally
slightly press it away from you so it's
a far more natural movement for your
shoulder
you don't have to like do all these sort
of like weird
lower back extension to get the bar in
the air
and
it's far easier to progress you can add
like small plates to it and load it over
time and if you struggle with getting
the the bar into position start with it
resting on a box or resting on a bench
and then you just front squat it up
basically kneeling or standing
either
i do i do standing i'm a big fan of i'm
a big fan of standing over kneeling yeah
it's just i'm never stable enough when
i'm kneeling on the ground
because then you can do a proper like
one foot you know one foot forward one
foot back like power stance and yeah
really yeah really go for it it's a
shame that well there must be somewhere
i'm sure that there's some fancy gyms
that have got a way to do that um with
both arms at once
if the plates are big it might get quite
uh
oh yeah hey
uh yeah landmine pressed for shoulders
and it's so
it's so safe
you know you need to just feels right
doesn't it just feel like the right
thing to do but that's because you've
managed to take a movement that was
supposed to be pressing vertically and
made it go a little bit more close to a
bench press
[Laughter]
right so
if you lie under it like that
feels even more right yeah and then if
you take it out of the land mine
actually put it into a rack yeah you can
just do bench press
this is a landmine press variation that
you can do
it's back to where we all started which
is lying down lying down feet not on the
floor yeah completely isolated bench
press uh seth
this is one that i got from elliot holtz
of all people
which is if you are
having one of those days where you're
just like i just cannot be bothered
to do the session that i've got and this
particularly if you've
been following 531 for the last seven
years as you should be and you're long
bitcoin
then
there is a point where the numbers get
to the point where like and we've all
experienced this like thursday night
before your squat day for heavy threes
and you're like
oh i don't know if i can even
face getting out of bed in the morning
because i've got this this thing coming
up
if your training consistently starts to
feel like that just go in
and say right i'm not allowed to lift
more than 60 kilograms for three sets of
10 for everything and
you have to just turn up go through the
motions you're not allowed to give it
any intensity not allowed to like it
literally you just turn up and just go
through the motions like you can even
have that face just
and he's and he's right that by the end
of that session you'll be so
like fired up to actually do it properly
again
that solves the problem whereas if you
try and push it when
something in you is just like ah i'm
exhausted
you're only going to burn out faster so
what's the
the principle here that if you're
struggling with motivation
reduce the load
move through the session and use the
whatever like latent desire to train
properly to
like the boredom kicks you into the the
next session correctly absolutely yeah
do you ever do that johnny do you ever
well you know because you are pres you
are basically controlled by a man on the
other side of the internet with your
training aren't you it's worse than that
actually i'm controlled by a very
intricate spreadsheet that i don't
understand it's run by a man
so i
tell the spreadsheet every day how i
feel
seriously and then the spreadsheet tells
you the spreadsheet says well this is
what you should do so it's kind of
adjusted and adapted for me
i i have a i have a one actually my neck
it's weird my next one is very linked to
that but i'll let you go um
this is the most overused hack of all
time so if people haven't already seen
this i'll be very surprised but we
haven't used it before james smith and
sunny webster got into a fight on
twitter about who was able sorry on
instagram about who was able to use this
first but just if you have a barbell
which is on the floor and has a lot of
plates on it stick a small plate under
the closest to the collar plate that's
on the floor roll it up and over it and
it means that you can deload the bar
so much more easily you'll save your
lower back and you've always been in
that position especially if you're in a
gym which isn't built for power lifting
where the the rubber gym 80
plates are something they're like a gold
plate and it's with
rubber that makes you stick it's like
teflonized rubber or some [ __ ] and it
just doesn't come off and you know this
is impossible to get off
roll the barbell up kick it onto a plate
pull everything off the end there you go
you've only got one plate left do the
same on the other side you've deloaded
the bar far easier now you could go to a
gym that has a bar jack or like a bar
rack like a laco thing to properly kick
it up but
i actually think that this is probably
quicker
as a
for a tip for people who've like never
been to the gym before this is the first
year they're going to the gym i've seen
it happen so many times where people
don't appreciate the
like if you strip all the one side of
the barbell if it's like on a rack or
like an easy bar for example on a
preacher kill you'll see people strip
one side of it and then it goes
like that and the the straight into the
face into into someone else lying on the
bench next to them or whatever so like
unload barber when they aren't on the
ground unload them
evenly one side after the other learn
basic physics
moment do you know why i think this
slightly it's slightly forgivable is
the barbell especially 20 kilo like a
six foot barbell you look at it and
think that can probably
that could that probably be all right
like it doesn't look immediately like
that's an uh that person's in imminent
danger my ability to judge
how much weight
like how much weight the fulcrum or
whatever needs in order to flip it over
i have no idea absolutely no idea i
always err on the side of caution
because i've seen this happen one too
many times and you're that's the
equivalent of being a server in a
restaurant and dropping the glass
everyone
[Music]
of trying to push that fulcrum yeah it
can take two twenties on one side
without flipping
three twenties is touch and go
so this is a dude this is a this is a
[ __ ] life hack explain what the
limits are of a
the way i would unload 180
right so that's four 20s each side
is as follows
you go to one side and i strip off two
twenties
okay
leave two twenties on
that bit's very important leave two
twenties on go around to the other side
and strip all four
because it will not flip oh and then go
around to the other side again
that's proper tetris like minimum number
of strokes required to yeah i think you
could probably push it to like take one
off and then but you've already got to
do two carrying 40 kilos isn't too hard
there's a you can tell when it's at its
limits the way i check if i'm not sure
is um because if you're using like 25s
or anything just give it a little yeah
give the other end a little bit very
light you think no probably not for me
if someone touches that that's going
over before you do your one johnny
here's a just a thought about that thing
that you did there seth if you're
struggling with motivation we're
probably going to be getting toward the
stage where people are starting to hit a
little bit of a limit especially if
they're used to if they're in a new
training routine if they're training at
a different time or if they're first
stepping into the gym after a little bit
of a break
what are some of the things that you do
to get yourself
motivated or in the mood for training
if you're just thinking oh like i'm i'm
totally totally not down for it today
either
supplements or movements or routines or
mindsets or anything
i would say don't use a pre-workout
these things are false economies
what does that mean
i don't agree with that so
are very strong stimulants usually with
a bunch of experimental
stuff in there
to get you
amped and to make sure that you don't
sleep for the next two days um so that
so that you can lift another rep on you
on your incline curl or something
but
you pay the price much more on the back
end of it
so i'd be very sparing with that if you
are a coffee drinker and it's before 2
p.m
yeah just have a regular coffee before
the thing but don't go and buy something
that's a derivative of an amphetamine
just so that you can
do a couple more cable incline
i love how careful you are with
stimulants
you have become remembering that we back
in the day wouldn't have thought twice
about having vodka water and
no explode from bsn
that was a that was a pre-night drink
for me
some of my best sessions were with like
an mr and met rex sample that came on
the front of a flex magazine and i like
goodness knows where i had it just out
of the packet because i didn't have a
shaker with me and then went and trained
yeah well yeah so i i should frame this
that i'm i'm talking about this as a an
ex abuser of
all these kind of supplement retirement
retiree you're a veteran yeah where you
just dry scoop the like three scoops of
doing a scoopy jack 3d or whatever else
yeah
so let's look at the serving size of
jack 3d and thought that doesn't matter
did you see there was a video that came
up on youtube the other day some guy did
an entire
tub
of original jack 3d oh my god
i mean that's surely what's happening
pretty sure i'm pretty certain that
derrick from more plates more dates did
a reaction video to it um
about just what was going through this
guy's system
pretty [ __ ] all right so i mean i
would be calling the anaesthetist like
if i had a patient that said i've had a
tub of jack 3d i'd be like right
yeah make a couple of phone calls make
sure like they're ready
um what do you do if it's i'll get to
you in a second johnny if you don't like
the idea
of
relying on stimulants what do you do to
get yourself let's say it's an
aggressive session or you really want to
go in and crush it what do you do
yusuf
you're asking me yes
so a lot of it
is because you've got stuff at home that
you're like
well for me it's like i've got work i
need to finish and i've got all these
little bits and i can't really justify
going to the gym and and then
oh you know that on those times that you
don't go and you try and stay and do the
the admin stuff
it's an hour later and you're like was
it really worth it
no
so i think just knowing from past
experience that
whenever you try and skip the gym
the time that you would have spent
otherwise is
usually rubbish and
your energy is still low and stuff
whereas if you go and you come back and
you're like okay i feel like i've had a
frame shift i'm re-energized as you said
chris a while ago it's the same as or
it's more didn't you than the shift that
you get from
an eight-hour night of sleep yeah your
mood changes more pre and post-workout
than it does when you go to bed versus
when you wake up i think yeah no one is
treating yourself like a child like
putting in your calendar and being like
i'm gonna do it because i will gotta go
i think not overthinking it is probably
a pretty good
principle okay i just i'm robotic here
i'm working for the boss the boss said
that i gotta go at the gym so i go to
the gym i also think that um
apart from the times when you injure
yourself which isn't usually due to the
workout it's due to something else
that's going on
you almost never regret going to the gym
apart from the times i've injured myself
and even then i don't regret going to
the gym i regret the injury which was
caused by something else not to do with
really cold or yeah
yeah exactly i was fatigued or stressed
or whatever um
yeah you you almost are never going to
regret a gym session and keeping that in
your mind good look if i do this it's
something that future me will thank me
for
current me is a lying
duplicitous [ __ ]
and you you cannot listen to him future
chris will thank you for it
uh johnny give me the justification for
obsessive
caffeine and stimulant use
well so i just
i kind of think that
everybody should experience that safely
once
because if you've never had a
pre-workout before
um
it ends up being quite a good session
what say because i haven't used a
pre-workout in so
not five
um
the last time i experienced anything
close to it was when i didn't have
coffee for a month and then had an
espresso and went and trained and that
was
yeah
can we all just say our story from first
time you ever had a pre-workout
mine was that i just had when you hadn't
had a coffee in a while no no i had a so
there was a sachet like a sample sachet
of
metrics whatever it was their pre their
version of jack 3d
um that version of no explode and i
didn't have a shaker cut with me so i
just had it as a powder dry and then
went and trained i was like
bareback
yeah like that was
what was yours youssef never liked that
again is it so yeah it was it was just
chasing chasing the
proverbial pre-workout dragon
it was the the original jack 3d with the
dmaa in it which is
the the amphetamine and i found myself
like gurning
um
you feel
pulse-rated like really like listening
to like new monkey on the way to the gym
and you're like this is excellent
um my my three rep max for squats was
140 kilos at the time and i remember
turning up and i did a set of
if there was a seven rep pb
completely unheard of the biggest like
difference pb that i've ever done in my
life
i hobbled home
and
was ill for a week like really flu type
symptoms for a week
and then i remember the next week
um i had another dose of it and my
father was like what's that can i try
some she didn't lift and i was like yeah
sure and so she she had a scoop and i
went to the gym came back house was
spotless
and she was like oh you've had a really
good day i've cleaned the whole house
and it feels really good i'm like oh
okay interesting the fact that you're on
amphetamines
she was no stranger to her class a's as
well so
it's uh crazy that they were able to
sell that all right johnny what do you
do you you
going to go and do a workout and you've
got some pretty heavy sessions that you
need to do how do you get yourself in
the mood
uh so the first thing is like a
a like a planning consideration so try
and train on the same days of the week
at the same time
and try and
plan stuff so that you can't in the rest
of your week so that you can't move the
session
so i quite like having that like i i try
to not let myself train less than three
times a week i just is this just this
standard of like i feel like 16 year old
me would be really disappointed to me if
he found out that i trained less than
three times in a week so
i have those slots
and the fact that i have this rule of if
i'm not going to train tonight i'm not
doing that session this week is often
enough to just get me in the gym
so and then i just have this rule of
no matter how i feel
i'll go and just do a walk i'll go and
just like do something
and most of the time
it ends up it ends up happening um and
then
like some of the sessions are happening
stuff like having the for the long time
life hacks listeners they'll know that
this is a life hack and they'll all be
using it already but having a sacred
playlist
that like is what you is what you listen
to when you warm up or is what you
listen to when you train really helps um
or like even just watching some stuff on
youtube so like having a time when you
finish work especially if you're working
from home you're like okay five o'clock
emails get emails [ __ ] i'm gonna watch
some like fitness stuff on youtube like
i'm gonna watch
crossfit videos or piloting videos or
whatever on youtube to like get me in
the mood and i'm going to go to the gym
um but this links into my next hack
actually
just so well planned doesn't it fire
away
um
for people who so either in that
position where you regularly find
yourself like i can't really be bothered
i don't want to go or if you play around
with like if you have a woot band or an
orange or whatever and you don't know
what to do with that
information something i've done with
clients in the past is you have
your session so your monday session
and you split it into three so you have
like an a b and a c
so if you're feeling really good or you
have loads of time or your weight band
gives you a green rating or whatever you
do the full thing
if your whoop band or whatever gives you
an amber or you're like a bit short time
i can't be bothered do a and the b or
you just do the a so you chunk it into
you like order regulating based on time
mood energy
whatever things you track how much sleep
you had last night
but the a section the smallest bit
should always be something that like you
can always go and do it's like useless
version of the
60 kilos for a set of 10 like there
should always be a minimum that you can
tick the box of
um and it means that if you want to use
something like a wood band because i
think what we've all struggled with in
the past is you have that and then
you're like what the [ __ ] do you do with
the information yeah like it's red and
it's flashing and it's shouting at you
like stop being a child and get more
sleep and you just go train anyway
you're like well
[ __ ] it's kind of point find a pointless
right whereas if you can at least scale
back your session
at least you're doing something you're
like paying some respect to that
information if you if you choose to
believe it so basically taking your
existing training program
chopping each session into three
sections and then you can just adjust
depending on how you feel or how much
energy how much time you have
[Music]
nice
the other
frame shift for this
of just
stepping back and big picture the you
know the old like look out at the stars
and see how insignificant you are is
just saying
rather than oh i have to go and train is
i get to go and train
there are people who
would love to but aren't able-bodied
enough to do it or or what were talking
about before they feel so intimidated by
the scary gym environment and all of
their internal projections about
fat phobia and everything that they
can't even make the first step and and
actually
it's a great privilege a great ability
to go and celebrate your body and well
one day one day you are going to be
80 and
in a care home or you know unable to
lift any heavy weights and you go like
back in the day i used to do 50 kgs
strawberry two scoops first thing i am
telling you man that would be old people
in 50 years wouldn't it listen yeah good
man honestly talking about jack 3d in
the care home rub
we used to have this thing called
tickety-tock
uh so my one that you touched on there
johnny is
i think the obvious solutions are the
ones that people overlook when they need
to get motivated to go and train
just find a song
that
complete you cannot not get amped for
like have you played this training yeah
or just there's a few of them right if
you put that on it was your pre-drinking
song for uni or it was whatever your one
rep max song for the gym if you throw
that on there is
you would be amazed at the state shift
before and after that three and a half
minutes have let the bodies hit the
floor
try
try and tell me that you don't want to
go and lift the [ __ ] out of the gym
after that
like it's just it's such a state shift
and it's so obvious everyone's got songs
that get them amped up all right just
use that use those
live on youtube
that's your one that's still in the
that's in the first life hacks
like listening to live bands on on
youtube man or like live dj sets yeah
well as well when you've got the
audience in the background the energy's
so good yeah like i just need one of
those on and that the nice thing about
them as well if you get the full set it
can be the whole session yeah and like
you're finishing the session as they're
doing like their encore and coming back
on for one final song yeah it's
brilliant
you know life-changing
uh what have i got here um this is just
one that i've had so
tyneside where i train at in newcastle
has just got a
um seated
car phrase machine so the ones that work
as you sat down you load the plates on
the front the pad sits on the top of
your knees
and we've just found that
adding that in in between what there is
nothing that you're doing that can't
have calves added in in between but no
one can ever be bothered to dedicate
ending stuff all right maybe if you're
doing squats or rear for elevated lunges
or something like that but you no one's
looking at the car phrases in between
car yeah when you're training cars the
other thing that you should really look
at is adding calves in between sets but
if you're doing like a bench press or if
you're doing anything upper body just
get
four or five rounds of an easy calf
machine or set the
leg press up and do calf raises on the
leg press in between
so someone sent me i must have tweeted
something about calf training
or having small calves and someone
tweeted me a bunch of studies
that are like
we compared a group of people over 16
weeks training
calves heavy twice a week versus heavy
three times a week or um
light unheavy or progressively doing
this and
all of them showed zero muscle growth no
way
no [ __ ] way across the entire study
like any and it's just basically like ah
so calf training is just a scam then is
it like why is that the case do you
think yeah that can't be true just so
have so one theory is that they're so
heavily genetically determined and that
they you basically are training them all
the time because you're getting so much
loading from walking them walking around
with them
that they're that kind of muscle they've
already
hit their limit unless you were to go
absolutely harm on them like it might
just be that to get big cards you need
to you need to do a chris and like
between any set of anything go and sit
on the seated calf raise yeah well it's
interesting cause obviously the achilles
rehab that i did i went from having a
calf that was basically that didn't
exist total muscle wastage to now i
overshot it and the calf of the leg that
i recovered is now bigger than the calf
of the leg that i didn't
which is why i'm thinking about calves a
little bit for the first time ever
what do you say what what just that one
of the coaches from 3dmj jeff alberts
has got a like a side-by-side comparison
of like i mean this is probably 10 years
of calf training but he has legitimately
turned very average calfs into like a
strong body part for him so there's an
interesting point because jeff alberts
is all about mind muscle connection
isn't he he's missed a longevity
bodybuilder like
yeah and he's all about like getting the
most out of a set of 10 as you possibly
can how long was the study for
16 weeks so or like eight so the answer
is like 16 years then yeah
just do it for longer
they're definitely carbs and carbs are
certainly one of the hardest muscle
parts to train but also they're
probably the bottom of pretty much
everybody's list
yeah well i hate it don't they who they
and it hurts afterwards and it hurts at
the time and it's boring and it's yeah
all of the above so add it in in between
sets and you'll be sweet i think
i think that's me out
good list of some training things well
why don't we
why don't we finish up with any stuff
that we've watched or seen recently any
cool stuff
i got one it is well i'm watching it at
the moment called dope sick
on
disney plus
are you worried that we've already had
that
no
so it is um it's recommended by dan mr
digital audio broadcast
um
it's about
uh
oxycontin
the sort of the creation and
distribution is it the wesler family
uh
it's the something family isn't
something family but yeah i can't
remember the name of it but yeah
pharmaceutical business produces this
this oxycontin drug which is an opioid
that they claim has like slow release
and all sort of stuff and isn't
addictive and it's about like the
um the consequences of that and it is
a bit of a bit of a slow start but
is it a documentary no no it's a series
it's a drama series um based on i'm
going to guess
well it must be true right because
pretty accurately based on reality yeah
real i've had oxycodone it's a powerful
drug what's the difference between
oxycodone and oxycontin
it i think it's the trade names i've
never heard
oxycontin being used in the uk it might
be maybe
the slow release or i think yeah
formulation or something i think that's
it what was the one because they had to
change it so that people couldn't snort
it anymore is that the difference
between oxycodone and
oxycontin so in this oxycontin they like
the thing that supposedly slow release
is the coating of the tablet but people
put the tablet in their mouth for a bit
take it out crush it and snort it
so
so
but like the pharmaceutical expert thing
is just like a triggery coating around
the edge of the pill but yeah so i i i
mean this was a thing it like keeps
shooting back between like 1995 and
present day where there's like a lawsuit
being being built against them and i
haven't finished it yet but
so good yeah i've heard that before it
was being dopesick was being advertised
on the central
roundabout
in town yeah
as part of disney plus it looks awesome
there's also a book um maybe that the
series is based on or perhaps just the
same story reported by someone else i
was in waterstones yesterday and there's
a book all about this so i i can't wait
to watch that it looks
really really good so good so good seth
have you seen anything nice
i have actually i think it's the only
thing i've seen but it's called midnight
mass
on netflix
and it's fantastic it's a self-contained
seven part series
and it's based on a stephen king book
it's a roughly about
a guy who comes to this little parochial
village as a priest and he's really
charismatic and everyone likes him and
um it just
it's really nicely written and there's
lots of threads about
the weird kind of ego games that
religious people play and
how people get drawn into
to things based on their interpretations
and um
there's a there's like a muslim sheriff
there who like doesn't buy any of it
he's like no i'm not not getting
involved in this and it's very very
culturally accurate
in in some ways and uh
just really really good it's it's a
horror but it's not
it's not just like jumpy
shock
netflix
yeah cool
really recent as well i've not seen it
heard of it
have a look at the trailer
i think like
i'm not one of those ones with scary
stuff how's how jumpy and how scary are
we talking
not massively jumpy there's like maybe
four moments in the whole series that
are like
but like it's not about it's not one of
those things that's trying to like
scare you through shock factor okay does
it fill you with dread is there any
sense of dread
no sense of dread
[Laughter]
a bit of doom
from doom
any like nihilism at the end
a little bit okay sounds perfect it
sounds exactly like you know there's
three words at the top of the and it's
like
romantic zany
zingy
[Laughter]
so
i am a huge fan of netflix's colorized
world war ii documentary series and
they've had two already that were up and
a third one has just gone live which is
world war ii road to victory
so they've
gone back through particular
elements of world war ii so the invasion
of north africa the battle for the
atlantic the battle for dunkirk whatever
and they've colorized the
entire set of footage
so you get to see world war ii
in full color it's they've tried to hd
stuff as much as they can they get
really really good expert testimony they
get there's never i'm always a little
bit conflicted when you watch
war documentaries and they get the
veterans that were there on because i
quite like it but because everyone's
inevitably quite old it does slow the
pace of it down a little bit whereas
when they rely on the experts and
they've got
such and such from brunel university
this guy from king's college london
whatever whatever
and all of the historians are [ __ ] hot
they're really really good um it's just
great like this i think the new series
has got 12 episodes in it world war ii
road to victory
like
just easy watching and you get to it's
much more engaging to watch stuff
it just shows how overstimulated we are
the fact that going from black and white
to color means that i'm more likely to
learn about something that's interesting
to do with history
the episodes are a good length i think
there may be a full hour long uh but
yeah i highly highly highly recommend it
cool you watched anything else johnny
um
i'm try i've tried watching something
called the tourist as everybody oh dude
i didn't even get through the first
episode yeah
shame that isn't it yeah with what's his
face who was the guy that was in
christine gray
yeah from fifty shades of grey [ __ ] yeah
really really struggle with this shite i
just didn't think it was very good uh
what was the what was the one i think we
said this a little while ago
with the dude that plays loki from
the marvel comics uh the night manager
yeah the night manager with tom
hiddleston
yeah uh hiddleston
[ __ ] hell what an awesome awesome
yeah hugh laurie's in have you seen that
youssef did we tell you that one no the
night manager [ __ ]
really
worth watching oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
off the back of that that i think he
should be the new james bond
oh
right i'm gonna add these two how would
you feel about because i would be
completely down for idris elba to be the
new james bond idris elba would be good
tom
tom hardy or tom hiddleston it's got to
be one of those three yeah if you don't
they've all got the they've all got
their required attitudes to it they'd
all play a slightly different bond but
would all do well what would you choose
if you had to choose out of hiddleston
elba
and hardy
who would you choose
i want to say tom hardy just because i
like him in everything that he does
that's that there's his recommendation
actually
lock
you see that oh where is the welsh guy
and it's filmed in the car
unbelievable my housemate was watching
it last night i've watched it a bunch of
times but my husband was watching it
last night how like how to make just a
man in a car for what must be an hour
and a half completely like edge of your
seat watching the whole time yeah so
good similar to phone booth is the
concept then yes yeah yeah but even less
even more tuned down it's it's
even less exciting than ryan reynolds in
buried
have you seen that yeah i've seen that
where he's literally just buried for the
whole time yeah one scene for the whole
time i i can't remember what it is but
if if someone's interested in finding
out about it if you google how much lock
cost and how long it took to film
the whole thing was shot in a couple of
weeks and it cost like
500 grand it costs nothing
that's surprising to be honest because
it's just tom hardy in a car yeah i feel
like someone's
gonna be honest yeah decent camera and
two hours of tom hardy i think we could
have got it over the line yeah no just
give me a ring light and an iphone 500
crack it out no worries
uh yeah lock is
unbelievable and you've got do you know
who tom hiddleston tom hardy and idris
elba are yousef do you have any
no i think idris albert is the guy who
was in
you sure like his place sent the
midfield for england
with with johnny wilkinson that's it
um
the one who is in
he's the main character in some kind of
he's a detective he's like a luther
luther luther yeah i haven't i've never
watched that
what very very good is it i'm correct
i've started writing down now the
recommendations you guys have said with
your names in brackets because
there's probably not
luther should be should go top of the
list well dude the wire never seen it
sopranos never seen it definitely by the
way you've never seen the sopranos no no
i wouldn't bother with the wine
really
yeah
yeah uh i think
on balance tom hardy makes for
you remember when
you remember when
it went from being pierce brosnan
and everyone couldn't believe that you
were gonna have this like hard guy it
was gritty daniel craig was running off
the side of buildings he was coming out
of the water he was like jacked
and now think because that was i think
he first became bond in 2006.
yeah that's exactly right yeah um so
think about the fact that from then
until now
looking at daniel craig and comparing
him with the potential of tom hardy and
thinking hang on daniel craig was like
the hard aggressive dude and then you
see just how much more
extreme
uh movies have got
like the standard's really been raised
but i think to go to lean into it would
be a better way but i also think that it
would be quite cool to ha i think having
a black bond would be pretty cool that
would be like yeah idris would smash it
as well yeah he's a sick guy he's got an
awesome voice yeah um
i do know who tom hardy is because he he
played
charles bronson yes yeah he did he did
which
which in itself like if you're having
bronson is now bond that's
he's got a real uh repertoire he plays
the jewish
gangster in
peaky blinders yeah he's got the welsh
accent he's done also
cray twins
yeah he's both of them yeah
uh
he's well he's bane
in the in the batman's
serious guy serious serious guy
uh gentlemen thank you we made it
where should people go if they want to
check out what it is that you guys do
i think if you just want to run any
online business propanefitness.com
forward slash modern wisdom we show you
how to do it for free if you want macros
and calories propanefitness.com forward
slash calculator
we made it
peace what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you